Are you ready for this?
I am a sociology major with a minor in Asian American studies.
I'm an applied math major.
Russian, geography and environmental studies.
I am a sociology major.
I'm a math econ major and a film minor.
Class of 2017.
You know, it's always about the sunshine here in Los Angeles.
It's kind of a blessing and a curse because I need to study but every weekend there's
always something I want to be doing more.
There's like so many different cultures and foods to explore. I'm a huge foodie so.
I like that there are places open past 9 o'clock.
My favorite professor was Elizabeth Olsen.
Going to class didn't feel like going to class. It felt
like I was going and getting to like
watch a great Netflix special or something.
His name was Dr. Keith Camacho.
I've enjoyed all the times that we've hung
out.  And we even BBQ'd.
The class I'm taking right now. Barbara Boyles.  It's a producing class.
Learn about how  to actually make a movie in Hollywood.
I would tell my freshman self just to explore new things.
And be excited with the people you encounter over here.
Just to enjoy the roller coaster ride.
The future is what it is and just enjoy the present.
Obviously, classes are a big part of UCLA
and it's important to focus on things
like internships and classes and jobs.
But, nothing is really more important
than the personal relationships that you form here.
I'd tell this freshman self to get a haircut.
You're going to make all the right choices.
You're going to have a great time.
Don't stress too much about these choices. And live life to the fullest.
Eat enough food. Drink enough water. Get enough sleep every day.
Do the school spirit thing. Go to the bonfire go to the games.
Tip number one:  make your meals ahead of time.
Tip number two: visit the Writing Center more often.
Broaden your horizons. Not just take a class because it fulfills a requirement
or fits for your major. Take classes that you're really generally interested in.
Extra tip: say thank you to mom and dad every week that you're on campus.